how are you doing today sir very well
thank you how are you welcome
to the jungle exactly i mean
i mean the the ride is right here i
can't wait to the to the
to the passengers from here but we're
safe here so which is uh
which is something i feel very grateful
about like the the big effort that
everyone has put into
into making it safe for everyone and
last night at the premiere
you know it's a great example that when
you come together and you get organized
and you care about each other
then you can you can make you can make
things happen you know
so let me start by saying how much i
enjoyed this movie
it is such a fun adventure uh there's no
way people are not going to like this
film
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
what do you think might surprise uh
people to learn about the making of
jungle cruise
uh well based on the based on the
questions that i've been getting
throughout the entire
um uh press campaign for this film um
specifically about the visual effects
and um and um
the amazing visual effects is how
much was mechanical and real in the
movie
meaning that meaning that the sets were
built
um the we we worked on
a lot of real locations out in the open
a lot of the of the big of the big
stunts you know with with you know the
boats and um
and the submarine they were all they
were all real they were all mechanical
effects that
as they were they would have done it you
know in the 80s like in big movies big
sagas
like indiana jones so that was very that
that is very refreshing and in terms of
my character specifically aguirre i
didn't have any makeup i mean basically
it was like a few dots you know for the
computers to read
my movements but all the all the snakes
they were all
made you know through cgi and i had a
great time just
performing as i normally would would do
it so
um i was very it was very comfortable
for me so no
no uh expandex green suit or or big
green uh
green screens behind us or acting
opposite a tennis ball
everything was very very real i heard
this might not be true
i heard you took this movie uh so you
could get a disneyland passport for life
well now that you now that you mention
it i should
i have my publishes here i should get a
i should get a free whole pass
from now on thank you thank you for the
thank you steve for the for the
suggestion that is i it hadn't crossed
my mind but now i'm going to work on it
i'm going to say good luck i really do
hope i can get it somebody gets it
i'm going to say good luck and i hope
you get it thank you
have you tried no i would never get one
i mean
you know you know of other of other um
actors that have become part of the
disney universe that have gotten it or i
i don't want to go any further than to
say good luck you i hope you get it
so you know something that i don't know
okay okay good i will
i will work into that um i
uh i think that um it can't it must be
amazing to be part of a movie on this
size and scope
what what is it really like behind the
scenes when you're making something like
this because
i think a lot of people don't realize
the hundreds of people that are working
on this yeah it is exactly i mean the
answer is in the question it is exactly
what you just said
to me i'm very i really love i really
love cinema
and i really love making movies i love
everything about it
um i started i started working as an
actor in movies because that's where my
my curiosity and my love and my
excitement lies um
lies in so um uh for me just
watching just waiting around for the
resets was an experience i mean we would
we would take 30 minutes up to 30
minutes to reset
for 15 seconds of shooting because the
amount of detail
that that went into every frame there's
no
easy quick frame you see a hand in this
movie
and it took 30 minutes you know to reset
for another take
and it's incredible it is incredible the
am it is a military operation it's
almost like an invasion i mean it's
gigantic the amount of people
working in front and behind the camera
to make something like this possible i
love it it's such a
it's such a great honor and and on a
personal level it's so
it's so special to be part of a movie
that is
that is based on the most iconic you
know ride
from the most iconic entertainment
universe in history which is disney it
is really special to be part of a movie
that is so epic so big uh so lush and
exuberant
it was incredible just to see just to be
behind
just just walking around waiting to be
waiting to be on waiting for action just
to see the level of craft
that was put into this i have to stop
there i mean it congratulations for
being part of this
and i'm also looking forward to
borderlands thank you very much yeah
we'll talk about it
for sure cool have a great day